قال رئيس الحكومه الانتقاليه المكلف في
ليبيا عبد الرحيم الكيب ان المرحله
الانتقاليه التي تمر بها البلاد تكتنفها
تحديات كبيره ولم يطرح الكيب في اول مؤتمر
صحفي له بعد اختياره اي خطط محدده بشان
المرحله الانتقاليه لكنه تعهد بالعمل على
بناء دوله تحترم حقوق الانسان وتفكيك
الميليشيات المسلحه المنتشره في
اللاد نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
عنوانين رئيسيين ما هي المهام الانيه التي
تنتظر الحكومه الجديده وما مدى قدرتها على
تجاوز التباينات
الجهويه وما هي تحديات الاساسيه التي
تواجه حكومه الكيب في المرحله الانتقاليه
التي ستمر فيها
ليبيا بدت ايام ليبيا الاخيره حفله
بالتطورات فصفح ثوره الفاتح التي امتدت ل
42 عاما طويت بمقتل القذافي ومهمه النيتو
التي استمرت سبعه اشهر انتهت رسميا مطلع
هذا الشهر هم الليبيون يختارون زعيما
لقياده مرحله انتقاليه لثمانيه اشهر هذه
التطورات تبدو منجزات مهمه بالنسبه الى
الليبيين لكنها مجرد علامات على طريق بناء
الدوله والمجتمع الخارج من ركام اربعه
عقود من سياسات داخليه هشمت بنى المجتمع
الليبي ومغامرات خارجيه بددت جزءا كبيرا
من
ثروته
اسلاك كثيره ومتشابك وخطره سيكون على
مهندس الكهرباء الليبي المخضرم عبد الرحيم
الكيب ان يعيد فكها وتشذيبها وتوصيلها في
مختلف ارجاء بلاده بعد من تخيب رئيسا
لحكومه مؤقته هي الاولى في مرحله ما بعد
سقوط حكم العقيد معمر القذافي الرجل الذي
يحمل شهاده الدكتوراه في الهندسه
الكهربائيه وسبق له ان شغل مواقع اكاديميه
ومهنيه هامه في دتي قطر والامارات فضلا عن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي نال من
جامعاتها ايضا شهادتي الماجستير
والدكتوراه انتخب الى منصبه الرسمي الرفيع
بغالب نسبيه ضئيله اذ حصل على تاييد 26
عضوا فقط من اصل 51 يشكلون المجلس الوطني
الانتقالي وهو ما عكس الى حد كبير خارطه
تنافس معقده يختلط فيها السياسي بالمناطق
او الجهوي وفق بير المغاربي الشائع كما لا
تخلو بحسب راي مراقبين من حسابات شخصيه
ونفع بيد ان الاهم من كيفيه وخلفيات صعود
الكيب الى رئاسه الوزراء سرعان ما وجد
تعبيره في الحديث المستعر لا يزال بين
مختلف الاوساط الليبيه عن مهمات شاقه
ينبغي عليه انجازها خلال فتره الشهور
الثمان المقدره عمرا لحكومته كي يصبح
ممكنا في اعقابها انتخاب مجلس وطني سيتولى
بدوره وض دستور للبلاد وسيمه الطريق امام
انتخابات برلمانيه ما هي خيارات رئيس
الوزراء الجديد لتاليف حكومته العتيده
يتساءل الليبيون الان وهل سيشكلها من
التكنوقراط ام من ممثلي طيف الثوره
ونجومها السياسيين والى اي التيارات سيميل
الاسلاميه ام الليبراليه في حال رجحت لديه
الاعتبارات السياسيه على المهنيه وماذا عن
علاقته المستقبليه مع المجلس الوطني
الانتقالي برئاسه المستشار مصطفى عبد
الجليل ثم الى اي حد سيكون في وسعه ان
يتجاوز وظيفه تسيير الاعمال ويبدا مبكرا
باعاده البناء واتخاذ القرارات
الاستراتيجيه في محاوله الاجابه على هذه
الاسئله وسواها تتعدد الاجتهادات من قائل
ان الملف الامني ينبغي ان يتقدم على كل ما
عداه في ظل فوضى السلاح التي تعاني منها
ليبيا وعاصمتها طرابلس على نحو خاص الى
قائل ان المطلوب من رئيس الحكومه المؤقته
يتعدى هذه المهمه على اهميتها ليشمل العمل
من اجل كل ما يقطع مع الماضي الاستبدادي
ويفتح الابواب امام مستقبل قوامه
الديمقراطيه وحقوق المواطنه اضافه الى
التوزيع العادل للثروه وباستعراض الهندسه
الكهربائيه التي جاء الكيب من وسطها
الدقيق والحذر قد يبدو تشكيل الحكومه على
يديه اشبه بصنع لوحه تحكم سياسيه لا
الكترونيه طبعا حتى يستطيع الامساك عبرها
ومن مكتبه في طرابلس بمفاتيح التيارات
السياسيه والقوى الثوريه المسلحه التي
تنتشر في مختلف انحاء البلاد بما يمنع
تصادمها ويوحد جهودها وطاقاتها جميعا في
سبيل بناء الدوله الديمقراطيه المنشوده بل
الملهمه ايضا لثورات عربيه شقيقه اطاحت
حكام بلدانها المستبدين واخرى سواها ما
زالت
تحاول للمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من
طرابلس محمود شمام مسؤول ملف الاعلام في
المكتب التنفيذي الليبي ومن لندن ينضم
الينا انيس الشريف المتحدث الاعلامي باسم
المجلس العسكري كما ينضم الينا من طرابلس
عز الدين عقيل الكاتب والباحث السياسي
وابدا معك سيد محمود شمام من طرابلس
اختيار عبد الرحيم الكيب
الاكاديميه هل يعطي انطباعا بان الحكومه
ايضا ستكون حكومه تكنوقراط تشبه
رئيسها ليس بالضروره السيد دكتور عبد
الرحيم الكيب شخصيه سياسيه ايضا وهو شخصيه
معتدله يحظى
باحترام كافه الوان الضيف السياسي وغير
السياسي الليبي وبالتالي القول بانها
ستكون حكومه تكنوقراط قول غير دقيق
ربما اسف
ربما ان تكون
حكومه اهم فيها في اعتقادي هي الاعداد
للانتخابات
القادمه نحن لدينا مشكله شرعنا اذا صح
التعبير حيث المجلس الانتقالي الذي بدا
شرعيا ويحظي باجماع الليبيين بدا يتوسع
باستمرار
وبطريقه عشوائيه وليست طريقه منظمه او
طريقه منتخبه وبالتالي اصبح لدينا اعضاء
كثيرون في في المجلس الوطني الانتقالي
ولهذا الانتقال الى مرحله الشرعيه عبر
صناديق الاقتراع كان اجمل ما في المشهد
ليله الماضيه هو اول صندوق اقتراع وضعت
فيه اصوات نريد ان ان توضع اصوات اكثر ليس
فقط لرئيس الحكومه ولكن حتى لاعضاء المجلس
الانتقالي
والمجلس الان يعني هذا هذا يقودنا الى
السؤال عن مصير الان المجلس الانتقالي
الحالي باعضائه الذين
توسعوا كما قلت لك لدينا ثمانيه اشهر حتى
انتخابات المؤتمر الوطني حتى الان ليس
هناك تحديد لعدد المقاعد ولا كيفيه
الانتخاب ولا الدوائر الانتخابيه ولا ما
هي الكثافه السكانيه كل هذه الامور يجب ان
تحسمها هذه الحكومه حتى يستطيع الشعب ان
يطمئن ان هناك انتخاب انا اسال هنا عن
المجلس الانتقالي سيد شمام وصلاحياته التي
هل يمكن ان تتضارب هنا مع صلاحيات الحكومه
مصير هذا المجلس
واعضائه المجلس الانتقالي كانت دائما
صلاحياته تتضارب مع صلاحيات الحكومه لانه
ليس هيئه تشريعيه بالمعنى المفهوم للهيئه
التشريعيه وليس حكومه انتقاليه بمفهوم
الحكومه الانتقاليه وبالتالي هناك عده
ملفات هي في قبضه المجلس الوطني الانتقالي
وهناك لجان موازيه على سبيل المثال لعمل
الح الوزارات الاخرى وبالتالي ما لم تحل
هذه الاشكاليه سيكون هناك تعارض بين
الحكومه والمجلس الوطني الانتقالي ولكن
كما قلت لك صندوق الاقتراع هو الذي يحسم
شرعنه او شرعيه كل هذه الاجسام السياسيه
انيس الشريف المتحدث الاعلامي باسم المجلس
العسكري اي سيد انيس انتم كم مجلس عسكري
ناطق باسم الثوار كيف تنظرون الى عبد
الرحيم الكيب وطريقه اختياره وامكانيه
التعاون معه
مستقبلا يعني نحن نعتبر ان تسميه رئيس
للوزراء هو تحرك في في الاتجاه المطلوب من
حاله الجمود نحن نعرف ان هناك مده وسقف
زمني محدد في الاعلان الدستوري لتشكيل هذه
الحكومه ب 30 يوما منذ اعلان
التحرير المامول ان يتم تشكيل الحكومه
داخل هذا الاطار الزمني السيد الكيب مطلوب
منه ان يشكل حكومه وطنيه حكومه انتقاليه
وطنيه تكون فعلا معبره عن ثوره هذا الشعب
الليبي يجب يعني ان نعرف اننا الشعب
الليبي انجز انجازا كبيرا بثوره عارمه
اسقط فيها نظام واقتلع من جذوره بالكامل
فمطلوب من هذه الحكومه ان ان ترتقي الى
هذا الفعل وان تمثل
هذه الامال التي عمل لاجلها الليبيون سيد
انيس يعني الملف الامني الملف الامني هو
احد اكثر الملفات الحاحا امام الحكومه
المقبله كيف سيكون تعاطي مع هذا الملف
وقبل تشكيل الحكومه هل لديكم مطالب من هذه
الحكومه على صعيد تمثيلكم بوزراء قبل
التعاون او الحديث عن تعاون مع هذه
الحكومه في هذا
الملف يعني ليس هناك مطالبه لا بوزراء ولا
بوزارات معينه بمقدار مطلوب من هذه
الحكومه ان تبني جسور الثقه مع كل مكونات
هذه الثوره بكل اطيافها المختلفه وكل
فعالياتها العسكريه وغير
العسكريه الجانب الامني ومعالجه الجانب
الامني هو احد ابرز التحديات المقبله امام
الحكومه التي يجب عليها اولا ان ان تملا
هذا الفراغ السياسي الحاصل الان في المشهد
السياسي الليبي ثم عليها ان تنتقل لتشكيل
مؤسسات الدوله وبد هذه المؤسسات الامنيه
واعاده تشكيل الجيش لتاخذ هذه الاجهزه الا
يه دورها فه هذا ياتي ضمن عمليه دمج لكل
هذه القوى الثوريه التي
تشكلت بان موضوع حتى حتى نفهم اكثر بان
موضوع سحب السلاح الان
و يعني وضع الملف الامني بالكامل بايدي
الحكومه ينتظر خطوات من الحكومه وبالتالي
لن يكون هو الملف الفارض نفسه
حاليا يعني بالتاكيد يجب ان ياتي هذا
الملف ظن رؤيه وطنيه جامعه لهذا الموضوع
لا يمكن ان ان ان يحل هذا الموضوع بقرار
صادر من الحكومه او بفرمان صادر من من
رئيس الوزراء او ما شابه يجب ان ياتي ضمن
نقاش وطني مع فعاليات هذه الثوره اللي
ينتقلوا جميعا من مرحله الثوره من مرحله
هذه التشكيلات الثوريه المتنوعه الى الاطر
الدوله الرسميه المؤسسيه دعني هنا اسال عز
الدين عقيل الكاتب والبحث السياسي من
طرابلس هل تفهم من كل ما تقدم سيد عز
الدين بانه س يكون هناك خلاف اولا على
التمثيل
اي السياسي داخل هذه الحكومه التمثيل
الجهوي وايضا على الاولويات فيما يتعلق
ببناء مؤسسات الدوله اولا او تثبيت الامن
ونزع السلاح من
اي المسلحين في الشارع
ثانيا دعني اخي بدايه اسجل اختلافي مع
السيد محمود شمام عندما قال بان الحكومه
القادمه ليس بالضروره ان تكون حكومه
تكنوقراط بل يجب ان تكون حكومه تعني
بالشان الانتخابي اعتقد ان الشخص المهدد
بجيبه وبقوه عياله لا يستطيع لا يفكر في
الانتخاب الشخص المهدد بامنه في الشارع
بسبب السلاح الفالت وبسبب المقاتلين
المستقلين لا يستطيع ان يفكر في الانتخاب
الشخص الذي يذهب عياله الى المدرسه ولا
يتلقون اي تعليم ويعودون ويقولون يا بابا
لم ندرس شيئا اليوم ولا داعي لان نذهب
المدرسه هذا الشخص لا يفكر في الانتخاب
الشخص الذي يفكر في ثروات بلده الطائله
التي تقدر بالمليارات المرميه في الخارج
والمعارضه للنهب حتى من قبل القوى
الاجنبيه والرسامين الخارجيه لان ليس هناك
من يرعاها والمال السائب يعلم السر لا
يفكر في الانتخاب اعتقد ان هذه لابد ان
تكون حكومه تكنوقراط حكومه كفاءات من
مستوى رفيع تفكر في شان المواطن تفكر في
الرفع من مستوى معيشه المواطن تفكر على
الاقل في اعاده المواطن الى الوضع اللي
كان عليه يوم 10 فبراير الحقيقه الوضع
الاقتصادي والوضع الامني هو في غايه صعوبه
خاصه في عاصمه البلاد واتمنى من الحكومه
القادمه ان تكون
نعم
تاتها الموا حتى هذه
اللظر فيما يعانيه اما بالنسبه لسؤال
حضرتك نعم نعم نعم نعم اما بالنسبه لسؤال
حضرتك المتعلق بالى اي مدى يمكن لهذه
الحكومه ان ان تخلق توافقا سياسيا مع
الاطراف الاخرى فاعتقد ان هذا هو التحدي
الاكبر الذي واجه السيد الكيب واعتقد ان
هذه الشخصيه هي شخصيه مريحه يشعر بالاطنان
تجاهها حتى الشخ الشخص الذي لم يعرفها من
قبل واعتقد ان هذا هو التحدي الكبير امام
السيد الكيب لان التيارات السياسيه
الموجوده في ليبيا كلها تتطلع خاصه الذي
شارك منها في صنع النصر وقيادات الثوار
المسيسين كلهم يريدون ان يشاركوا في صنع
القرار السياسي في بلادهم وهذا من حقهم
المشكله ان فقر الاماكن الى الان اللي
نعتقد ان قالوا 26 وزير مع اعتقد سبعه
هيئات هذا القدر من من المراكز المطروحه
اعتقد انه لا يكفي كنت اتمنى ايضا ان
المجلس الانتقالي بكامله يدخل في نعم هذه
المحاصصه يعني ال 51 شخص كان يجب ان ان
يتم استبدالهم بقيادات الثوار الذين
يحملون تطلعات الثوره الذين يستطيعون ان
يتفقون مع هذه الحكومه في كيفيه تصورهم
لليبيا الجديده لانهم هم الذين صنعوا
النصر على الارض للاسف معظم الاشخاص
الموجودين الان في المجلس الانتقالي هم
اشخاص اما جاؤوا من الخارج واما اشخاص
سبقوا الى كراسي المجلس بوقت مبكر لم
يشاركوا في ميادين القتال بشكل مباشر
وحقيقي كنت اتمنى ان السيد مصفى عبد
الجليل يضرب المثل
فعلا يعاود تلك الحكايه الرائعه للرجل
الرائع سوار الذهب بحيث يسلم رئاسه المجلس
الى الى الى شخص اخر حتى لو كان هناك
اجماع حول السيد المستشار كان بامكانه ان
ينقل هذا الاجماع هو يوصي الشعب الليبيين
خيرا بالشخصيه اللي يجيبها غير هؤلاء ال
51 شخص نعم نعم سيد عز الدين في فيما
يتعلق بالتحديات ساعود اليك انما بعد
الفاصل للحديث عن التحديات الحقيقيه التي
تواجه هذه الحكومه خصوصا فيما يتعلق بلم
شمل الشرق والغرب
والمناطق التي اعتبرت في الاونه الاخيره
مناطق ساخنه في ليبيا انتظرونا مشاهدينا
بعد
الفاصل اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في
حلقتنا التي تتناول استحقاقات وتحديات
المرحله الانتقاليه في ليبيا بعد اختيار
عبد الرحيم الكيب رئيسا للحكومه المقبله
واعود الى ضيوفي سيد محمود شمام اي عندما
نسال عن
التحديات لابد ان نتوقف عند كلام وزيره
الخارجيه الامريكيه هيلاري كلينتون بالامس
عندما تحدثت اي عن ان السياسيين الليبيين
الجدد ليس لديهم خبره سياسيه كبيره وان
اكبر تحدي امامهم هو المصالحه ما بين
الشرق والغرب بين بنغازي وطرابلس والقدره
على ضبط الامن الى اي مد تستطيع بان
ال الحكومه الجديده قادره على التصدي لهذه
المهام اولا ما قالته السيده
كلينتون
بصراحه ليس
دقيق وربما يصل الى درجه الهراء ليس هناك
خلاف بين الشرق والغرب لا احد في ليبيا
يقول هذا لا احد في ليبيا يشعر في هذا
وليس هذا موجود على الارض ولذلك المصالحه
الوطنيه بين من ومن المصالحه الشعب الليبي
باجمعه بكل قائه بكل قبائله وبكل مكوناته
بكل جهاته اجمع على الثوره واجمع على
مقارعه النظام القذافي حتى الذين وقفوا
معه حتى النهايه اعطيت لهم المهله تلو
المهله واعطيت لهم الفرصه تلو الفرصه لكن
سيد شمام هذا لا ينفي لا ينفي وجود خلاف
مثلا ما بين ثوار من الزنتان وثوار من
طرابلس على خلفيه جهويه لا لا ينفي مثلا
وجود مشاكل في بني وليد على خلفيه الموقف
السياسي وربما ايضا على خلفيه مناطق وكذلك
بالنسبه الى سرد بالنهايه بالفعل هناك
يعني هناك نوع من التفكك على هذا
الصعيد لا لا نبالغ فيه لا نبالغ فيه من
المهم جدا عدم المبالغه وعدم التهويل اولا
بالنسبه لما يحدث بين الزنتان وثوار
طرابلس هي اصطدامات مدنيه عاديه جدا وسوء
تفاهم عادي جدا لا يصل الى درجه القتال او
او التحدي او اي شيء من هذا القبيل اهالي
بني وليد اعطيت لهم الفرصه وقبيله بني
وليد اكبر قبائلها ورفله وهي قبيله منتشره
في كل اجزاء ليبيا وهي قبيله اجزاء كبيره
من من هذه القبيله شاركوا في في مناطقهم
في هذه الثوره اما عن سرد فقد فما حصل في
سرت معظم من هجروا من سرت موجودين الان
داخل مدينه بنغازي ويستقبلون اهالي بنغازي
ويرعون وبالتالي الحديث عن
مكونات جهويه او اقليميه او قبليه هذه
مبالغه سمج القبائل الليبيه اكثر وعيا
بالمجتمع المدني وبالدول المدنيه حتى من
بعض شرائح المدن وبالتالي هذا ليس ليس ليس
مطروحا ما هو مطروح هل نريد ان تستمر
المراحل الانتقاليه مرحله بعد مرحله ام
نريد ان نلجا الى صندوق الانتخابات حتى
تكون هناك شرعيه الاخ عقيل تحدث عن المجلس
الوطني الانتقالي وطالب باستقالته لا يجوز
ان نطالب باستقاله المجلس الوطني
الانتقالي دون توفر بديل اخر هو قال ان
ليس هناك داعي للانتخابات اذا استقال
المجلس الوطني كيف سنحسم قضيه المجلس
الوطني انا نحتاج لانتخابات وبالتالي قضيه
الانتخابات قضيه مهمه قضيه تاكيد شرعيه
الجسم السياسي الذي يقود البلاد الاموال
الليبيه لن نسمح بان تنفق او تسحب او او
تستثمر الا بحكومه منتخبه مرا شمام نعم
سيد شمام اريد ان انتقل للحديث مع انيس اي
الشريف عن
ال الصدامات المتفرقه التي تحصل في طرابلس
على الارض خصوصا وانه لم يجد اولويه لضبط
السلاح ول سحب السلاح من الشوارع يعني تحت
اي مرجعيه اذا سيد شريف سيكون العمل
الامني ومن الذي ومن المسؤول عن هذه
الخروقات على الارض في اكثر من منطقه
اخرها اشتباكات في طرابلس
بالامس يعني المامول ان تاخذ مؤسسات
الدوله حين تشكيل هذه الحكومه القادمه
مسؤوليه ضبط الامن عبر
تشكيل الاجهزه الرسميه الامنيه كالشرط
وغيرها يعني الثوار يجب ان ينتهي دورهم
الامني الثو هنا السؤال متى يعني انتم متى
تعتبرون ان دورهم قد انتهى اذا كانت
الاولويه ليست الان الى الملف الامني كما
تقول انا لم اقل ان ان الاولويه ليست
للملف الامني لكن قلت معالجه هذا الملف
يجب ان ياتي ضمن اطار مشروع وضمن اطار
اعاده تشكيل هذه الاجهزه الامنيه لا يمكن
اعاده الاجهزه الامنيه القديمه بتركيبتها
القديمه التي شاركت اجزاء كبيره منها في
قمع الشعب الليبي يجب ان يعاد تشكيل هذه
الاجهزه وفقا لاهداف وا امال وتط ثوره
السا من فبراير وفق رؤيه جديده يكون
مهمتها هي حفظ الامن والوطن وليس السهر
على حفظ امن انتم في العاصمه كمجلس عسكري
هل انتم هل انتم في العاصمه م مستعدون
مثلا لحل المجلس العسكري لصالح الانضواء
تحت مؤسسات الدوله والحكومه مباشره بعد
تشكيلها يا سيدي كل الاجهزه وكل التشكيلات
الثوريه يجب ان تحل في وقت ما ويجب ان
تنضم جميعا في اطار في اطر الدوله الرسميه
هذا امر غير قابل للنقاش لكن معالجته يجب
ان تاتي وفق رؤيه لا يمكن ان نتحدث عن حل
مجلس عسكري هنا وترك بقا بقايا التشكيلات
الثوريه في غيرها من المدن يجب ان ياتي
ضمن اطار وطني شامل اي في مساله ال
الخروقات الامنيه التي تحصل هنا وهناك في
العاصمه وفي غيرها نحن نعرف ان هناك جهات
معينه تلعب لهذا الدور تحرض على القيام به
ل والغرض منها هو محاوله عدم
اي اظهار ان الوضع يسير في الطريق الصحيح
من واجبات الحكومه القادمه ان تعالج هذا
الملف وان تشير بوضوح الى الاطراف
المتورطه في فرض هذه الفوضى اها اطراف
متورطه في فرض هذه الفوضى عيز الدين عقيل
ماذا تفهم من ذلك وهل تعتقد بان هذا الملف
سيكون اكثر تعقيدا مما هو متوقع ان على
صعيد اختيار الوزراء الامنيين او على صعيد
الدفع
باتجاه سحب
السلاح يعني بدايه اخي حسن اصحح سوء الفهم
الذي حدث عند الاخ شمام انا لم اقل بالغاء
المجلس الانتقالي الوطني انا قلت تغيير
الاشخاص الذين هم فيه بقيادات من الثوار
ومن الاشخاص الذين شاركوا بصنع النصر
وكانت هذه المهمه سوف تسهل مهمه رئيس
الحكومه بشكل كبير لانه رئيس الحكومه ليس
امامه الان الا 26 مركز وسته هيئات فقط مع
ان الاشخاص الذين يطالبون بالمشاركه
السياسيه وفي صنع القرار الخاص بالوطن هم
اشخاص كثر عند اذا ما اذا ما ما وضع امام
رئيس الحكومه فرصه اخرى وهي تجديد المجلس
الانتقالي ب 51 شخصيه جديده من الثوار
الذين فعلا سيساعدون الحكومه في نفس الوقت
على على وضع تصور للدوله كما كما يتصورونه
باعتبارهم شاركوا في صنع النصر هذا كان
سيكون مساعد كبير على لرئيس الحكومه على
تشكيل الحكومه في وقت سريع وكان سيرضي
اطراف كثيره نقشه فعلا ان تعرقل الحكومه
اذ لم يكن لديها نصيب او مشاركه في في صنع
القرار مستقبلا
اما فيما يتعلق بالصعوبات القادمه او
التحديات الابرز فاعتقد التحدي الابرز هو
تحدي السلاح الفالت وال والجماعات المسلحه
المستقله اعتقد ان هذه تشكل خطرا كبير
الان طرابلس اعتقد ان الامن في طرابلس هو
ناشئ عن توازن الرعب وليس عن امن محترف
ليس عن امن مصنع المساله هي كما قلت توازن
رعب ما بين اطراف مسلحه ربما معروفه لدى
بعضها البعض ولكنهم غير معروفين لمعظم
سكان المدينه نحن نعيش الان فعلا امن قائم
على توازن الرعب وليس على امن حقيقي مصنع
يستطيع ان يوفر للمواطن الامن متى ماحتاج
اليه اشكرك جزيلا عز الدين عقيل الكاتب
والبحث السياسي من طرابلس واشكر انيس
الشريف المتحدث الاعلامي باسم المجلس
العسكري وايضا محمود شمام مسؤول ملف
الاعلام في المكتب التنفيذي الليبي شكرا
جزيلا لكم جميعا بهذا تنتهي حلقتنا من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر غدا باذن الله قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد الى اللقاء
c